The solution is something that we've seen in the previous examples. In order to
update the move_dir vector, we query the state of the move-up, move-down, left,
and right actions. And adjust the movement vector accordingly. Once this is
done, we can test whether or not the length of the vector is equal to 0 or not.
This gives us the ability to determine if the user's even pressed a key. If the
user hasn't pressed a key. Then the length of mov_dir will actually be 0. We
can test this with the LengthSquared function. It allows us to then only call
normalize or multiply when a user has pressed a movement key. And of course all
of this data after being computed gets funneled into setLinearVelocity so we
can move our fancy awesome robot into the future. Now that we have the ability
to move the player around the world using keys The next step is to figure out
how they actually fire their fancy missiles towards the other robots.